foreign
[Music]
I'm currently still a PhD student but
starting my postdoctoral research at the
University of tuenta I'm working in the
Bios lab on a chip group and today I
have the honor to present you our work
which is entitled a crispr cast 12a
assisted in vitro diagnostic tool for
the identification and quantification of
single cpg methylation sites
so our ultimate goal is to detect cancer
in urine and actually detecting diseases
in urine is very old and is known in
Dutch as physical but in English as
uroscopy and this is actually the oldest
form of medical diagnosis and in that
time
medical people looked at the taste color
or consistency of urine to determine
whether someone had a disease
and although uroscopy is still a popular
part of science people don't look at the
taste anymore or the color they actually
look at the molecules that are inside of
the urine and one of the molecules
that's inside of the urine and we are
especially interested in is
hyperventilated DNA
so to understand why this
hyperventilated DNA is important for
cancer diagnosis I first have to explain
you a little bit more about genetics
information inside the cell
so every cell in your body contains the
same genetic code however your muscle
cells still look a lot different than
your lung cells and this is all possible
by the fact that your lung cells can
only look at the information that is
present
so all the other information is actually
locked so a lung cell cannot do anything
with the information of skin cells or
heart cells and this is only possible by
the by the by the process of
hyperventilation
so how does this schematically look like
now you can see over here so in the case
of low methylation or normal methylation
RNA polymerase can binds to the promoter
region and genes can be expressed
however in the case of hyperventilation
RNA polymerase kennel bind to the
promotion region and therefore genes are
suppressed and this is a normal process
in all cells of your body however if
this Gene suppression takes place in
critical growth regulator factors tumor
suppressor genes or genes related to DNA
repair or cell death tumor growth can
appear and therefore we're interested in
the detection of hypermethylation for
these specific genes and we want to
detect this in urine however that
doesn't matter it doesn't mean that we
can only detect bladder cancer because
if you for example have tumor cells in
your lungs those tumor cells now and
then excrete part of their genome via
extracellular fascicles or cell death
and then fire the bloodstream in the end
the small fragments can pass the filters
of the body which are the kidneys and
this is how it is hypermethylated DNA in
the ends can actually end up in urine
and this is where we want to detect it
and our partners at the Amsterdam UMC
the medical center in Amsterdam actually
showed that this is possible so for
bladder cancer they showed but that by
looking at the methylation profile of
two genes they can reach a sensitivity
of 92 percent and a specificity of 85
percent by determining whether someone
has cancer but just actually using pure
urine
so this is very interesting but how do
they actually do that
so what they do is they actually isolate
all DNA from urine and then perform a
bisulfite conversion which actually
means that all non-metinated cytoscience
are changed into uracils as you can see
in this figure
what they then perform is either
sequencing or what they mostly do
because it's cheaper is a form of PCR
like quantitative PCR and if they design
their probes or their uh
cons in such a way that only the
methylated samples will be Amplified and
then by
comparing the the amplification of such
a gene compared to a household Gene that
can actually determine the amount or the
concentration of methylated genes
however this method has some downsides
it's very time intensive and it's also a
very harsh method so there's lots of
fragmentation of the DNA sample and also
a loss of complexity
furthermore because of the quantitative
PCR methods it needs a fairly long
amplicon lens and therefore they cannot
look at single CPT sites and that could
be very interesting
so together with Amsterdam UMC we at the
University of twins and the Netherlands
are developing a new methods that is
faster and can be performed only in a
lap on chip device
so
unfortunately that doesn't mean that we
can just take their methods and put it
in a small chip we actually have to
develop new methods that are comparable
to their methods or maybe even better
so we came across crispr in this way
because crispr can easily be integrated
in point of care devices as we described
in our review paper
but how does crispr sensing actually
work for double-stranded DNA samples
well in our case we use cas12a which is
a crispr protein and over here you can
see a schematic of the mechanism of this
protein so this protein is associated
with a crispr RNA and what this protein
actually does is looking for both the
space adjacent motives and this dates
back from the time that crispr or it was
part of the
immune system of bacteria so it wants to
find the spam sequence to make sure that
it doesn't destroy its own DNA and now
we still have to deal with this because
yeah the crispr proteins we use are
still originating from this bacteria
so what we actually see is that one such
a pen mode of this found association
between the DNA and the crispr can take
place
and then the crispr can actually check
whether part of the crispr RNA is
complementary to the double strand of
DNA and if this is the case something
special happens so first the catalytic
site is blocked but during the arloop
formation which is the hybridization of
the target DNA with the crispr RNA there
is a change in the protein structure
which means that the catalytic sides of
her field and this is what we show in
this in figure C
what happens then is that since the
catalytic sites reveals the
double-stranded DNA can be cleaved but
after this cleavage the catalytic side
remains open and therefore also any
single stranded DNA that passes by could
be Cleaves for example fluoro frequency
DNA that is actually a fluorophy on the
quencher separated by a single stranded
DNA part but please note that the most
important part is the part we show in C
which is the part where the r Loop
formation takes place
and we broke this as I already said by
the cleavage of a fleur frequency but
how can we use this for quantitative
information
so over here you can see our typical
curve looks like when crispr actually
has a Target sequence so what you can
see is that the catalytic size is
refueled and that actually it starts
cleaving all three or four quenches DNA
in its neighborhoods
and we then can say something about
trans cleavage activity by looking at
the first derivative in the linear range
of this curve
so this is how we actually quantify by
the trans cleavage
how this art information takes place
however there's one big issue with
crispr and the fact that we want to look
at cpg methylation because crispr
doesn't see the Super G methylation
because it's not a change in the genetic
codes it is an epigenetic change that
actually cannot be seen by crispr so in
the end we develop the new methods that
make sure that Christopher can see this
cpg ventilation and today I will show
you how we actually do this by the use
of insert of an extra enzyme which are
methylation sensitive restriction
enzymes
by using these enzymes as you can see in
the first step of this figure we can
induce fragmentation that affects the
trans cleavage activity of crispr
because it affects the art of formation
and we are not the first to actually
observe this because if we look at the
famous paper by Chen at all we can see
in the supplementary information in this
figure but it actually used shorter
double-stranded DNA sequences and
checked what this affected the trans
cleavage activity and what we can see is
that although there are shorter
fragments which do not actually
complement the entire crispr RNA still
trans cleavage can be observed however
it seems to be a lot less than when
longer fragments are present so we
wanted to quantify this with a flu for
quench repair so actually looking at the
trans cleavage activity in real time
so we did this by using two different
spacers which is just the crisp RNA in
different lengths
um for both of these different lengths
we can see a very strong Trend with the
length of the target DNA
as you can see over here
so what we see is that for very short
fragments we see a very low trans
cleavage activity however for longer
fragments it translates activity seems
to almost literally increase up till a
certain point where it decreases again
and we'd be surprised by this because
we've actually thought in the beginning
that the longer the target's DNA is and
the more basis it complements with with
the crispr RNA the higher the activity
will be because we thought that we then
would have a better Trends our Lo
formation and therefore a better Trends
cleavage activity however when we dived
into literature we found a very nice
paper by Schwartz at all but it actually
showed with the crystal structure that
the last part of the crisp RNA is not
involved in the r Loop formation anymore
and this would explain the strength
as you can see in this part
so we can actually see no trans cleavage
activity for short fragments and
heightens cleavage effective for long
fragments but if we use ventilation
sensitive restriction enzymes what we
actually do is breaking a fragments in
two and breaking a fragmenting two means
that both fragments are actually still
present so what does this mean for our
crispr activity this is something we
observe in this slide so you can see
that the short length almost shows no
activity so that's the green one then
the yellow one is the longer fragment a
slightly higher activity and in dark
blue or purple we can see the full
length of the fragment
however the yellow green striped version
is actually two fragments being present
at the same concentration the same as we
expect when methylation sensitive X
restriction enzymes cuts to some point
too
restoring of the trans cleavage activity
which is simply by the fact that both
fragments can also bind to this crispr
RNA but just statistics
however the lower the concentration is
the lower this chance of burning is and
therefore the lower the trans cleavage
activity but even for 10 nanomolar
concentrations which is pretty high we
can already see a difference between
index
DNA and fragments of DNA so that seems
very promising
something we also wanted to see is
whether the cleave's position would
matter so we designed a Target sequence
as you can see on the left and we we
actually made sure that different
methylation sensitive restriction enzyme
Target sides would be present
and what we can see is that the cleavage
side really matters
so for example if we close close to the
bum there is a cleavage side which is
the hpa2 cleavage size we see a really
big decrease in the transgle effectivity
well if we cleave far away from the pump
we don't even see a red any change in
the transcripts activity and in this way
we can actually use these methylation
sensitive restriction enzymes to profile
where the methylation takes place so
actually we can look at single cpg
methylation sites and also see which
ones are methylates so that seems very
interesting
but of course we want to prove that we
can look at single cpg methylation by
using a More patient-like Sample so we
decided to order 120 base per fragments
which is also the length we expect to
find in urine and then we artificially
methylate the samples and we also had
samples that were not maximizes
then we added methylation sensitive
restriction enzymes to make sure that
all non-metalized DNA is fragmented and
all Metalized DNA stays intact
then in the next step we actually add
crispr and what we expect is that when
the fragmentation takes place the crispr
cannot perform the full art information
and therefore this effects in the end
the opening of the crisper and therefore
also the accessibility towards the clip
if it's shot so actually the trans
cleavage activity well for the metallic
DNA the entire frequency is index and
therefore we expect a high transcription
and that's what we want to measure by
looking at those three or four increase
over time
so first we actually had to see whether
this fragmentation was successful by the
use of methylation sensitive restriction
enzymes so we had crispr
not being present in the step we only
looked at the fragmentation and that's
what we show over here so we had
different ratios of methylated version
non-metalized as you can see that for
the fully methylated samples the
original Peak is a lot higher and for
the entirely non-methylated samples and
you can see a really nice Trend there so
we know that the methylation cells the
frustration enzymes are actively and
very specifically only cutting
non-metalized DNA so that's good
and then of course we want to see
whether we can show this with Crispers
so now we're introducing the crispr and
look at the fluorescence intensity over
time and because indeed see a very nice
linear Trend between the fraction of
methylated first non-methylated DNA and
amounts of translucent
so this is very promising
so with this research we were able to
show that fragmentation size of of the
DNA that you add to the crispr affects
its translativity and we propose that
that's because of this art information
that that actually is involved in the
revealing of the catalytic side
furthermore the concentration affects oh
the chance of multiple fragments binding
because we showed that if we have the 10
nanomotor uh Target DNA we see a lot
more restoration of the restoring of the
trans cleavage activity compared to for
example one nanomotor
and we also showed that the
fragmentation position affects the
translucent activity and this could be
useful for actually in the end
sequencing of the cpg sites
and we apply this by using the
methylation sensor restriction enzymes
that disrupt the arloop formation and we
showed that our essay is sensitive
towards single CPT site methylation
detection
however there's one big issue of this
essay and that is that we were only able
to go down to 100 Pico motor as a limit
of detection and this is an issue
because at the end we want to measure in
Europe
over here you can see a graph of the
expected constant DNA copies
concentration in urine in raw patient
samples isolate the patient samples
where we use a commercial kits or in
cell lines and you can see that we still
need to overcome a factor 100 000 to be
able to directly measure in urine
samples
so the big question is how to find this
hypermethylated DNA at ultra low
concentrations
it actually seems like finding a needle
in a haystack
so if we actually use this example of
finding a needle in a haystack what will
be the best approach
or we propose that the best approach
would be to actually
divide the haystack in really small
portions and per portion look whether
the needle is present
and then it's much easier to actually
find this needle
and this is what actually is the process
of digital sensing
so all our previous slides were based on
book or analog sensing and they're
actually the amount of signal directly
corresponds to the number of targets
another method would be single molecule
sensing where a signal is only
actually indicating that a molecule is
present or not
and what people usually do is making
very small volumes to make sure that
only one molecule can be present however
this is a very low throughput methods
it will be far more useful to have a lot
of these single molecule sensors next to
each other and perform digital sensing
where every event actually adds up and
by statistics it's possible to determine
the original concentration
and this is actually what people already
do
so yeah we think that the future will be
digital crispr essays and we also in the
end want actually to make sure that this
digital crispr SAS can be used in
combination with our methylation
profiling as I showed you before
there are many options options that
includes pre-amplification like in this
example where it combines with RPA or
even with lamp
or even without pre-amplification as was
shown for castrating a but also forecast
12a which is actually the guest 12 a
protein we're using in our essay
so hopefully in the future we will be
able to move our research forwards and
make sure that we can end up with a
digital crispr essay that allows
profiling of single cpg methylation
sites
of course this research was not done
only by me it was a collaboration of
many people of which the most important
are listed here during beers a postdoc
also working on Chris presenting and my
supervisors Professor young Aiko
Professor Luce the professor hence from
the Amsterdam UMC of which I showed you
today that earlier in this presentation
and of course our funders and with this
I want to enter presentation if you want
to know more about this topic you can
contact me by hitting this by simply
typing something in the ask a question
box and please submit this so I can
answer your questions by email thank you
very much